okay so let's start again this time we
have to admit give me the next talk
thank you for inviting me it's great to
be back here okay so I'm going to be
talking about time-space trade-offs
which I think a lot of you know about
it's an old topic in complexity and for
something called the memory game I will
introduce what the memory game is in a
bit but first let me do a bit of warm up
by saying how how we came to even think
of this problem say oh by the way that
the person who this is joint work with
you may not have heard of her yet she
was a brilliant undergraduate student at
Dartmouth she's now at Stanford and I
suspect you will hear for a lot - over
the next few years so here's an open
question from data streaming that I have
been interested in for embarrassing
number of years at this point we have
the stream of edges that form an end
vertex graph and let's say we want to
find the maximum matching in this graph
or find a maximum matching in this graph
so oh I have a typo over here this
should say N squared it's it's saying
nothing if it's in you know in a single
pass this problem is maximally hard
it requires n squared amount of space
and that's very very easy to prove it's
a straight it's a one-line reduction
from the index problem okay but if you
have more than one path suddenly it
seems very hard to prove anything and it
was not until pretty late that guru
Swami and onac in this fairly
non-trivial tour-de-force kind of paper
showed that with fee passes you need
slightly super linear space the the
extra the extra bit in the exponent goes
down by one over P roughly so somewhere
around log n passes this lower bound
bottoms out and you get nothing beyond
Omega n which is trivially the case
because the matching is the size of my
hand so I conjecture that the correct
space it frayed off for passes in space
should be that the product is omega N
squared and in fact I don't even know
that I can prove that as an upper bound
because if you look at how the
algorithms work you take even bipartite
graphs of prop car for something realize
how to get this to work in the streaming
model with a decent number of passes ok
anyhow so I wanted to say something
about this conjecture for a while
couldn't do anything about this so we
started thinking about that's about
lighter versions of the problem maybe
not actually matching itself but some
other kind of matching say okay so so
you know I was trying to find a topic to
work on with this undergraduate student
and we both like games card games in
particular as I understand tonight is
game night at Simon's right I don't know
if in any past game night people have
played this particular game but do
people know this game okay so some some
people know this has concentration so
yeah I mean India used to call this
memory so what it is is there's a bunch
of cards there's n pairs of them so the
2n cards every card has a picture on it
and each picture occurs exactly twice
and your goal is to sort of discover
this matching right so what can you do
in a move is just point to two cards and
then they get revealed and if they
happen to match then you take them away
from the game or maybe you just leave
the cards face up so they're basically
out of the game from then on and you do
this until you know the whole magic has
been revealed and the goal is to
minimize the amount of time taken the
catch of course is that you look at two
cards if they don't match you have
returned them back down and then after a
while maybe you've forgotten what what
was on those two cars so this game
actually has not been studied much until
recently and it turned out there's over
the last decade plus there's been some
amount of mathematical study of this
game so this is all of what I'm going to
say here is not really related to our
work but let me just say it anyway just
just so to give you an appreciation of
people what kinds of things people have
thought about so you can think of a
two-player version of the game which is
probably how you may have played it when
you were a kid so you're playing against
an opponent and when you find a match
you get to take those cards when your
opponent finds a match they go to take
those cards and the goal is to beat your
opponent by having more cards than the
afore
and so so this paper by a name I can't
pronounce properly I think I'll turn
Swedish car from kth showed that this
game has an element of strategy which is
actually not obvious it's not obvious
that this is not just a dumb luck kind
of game anyway so for the rest of this
talk I'm not thinking of the two-player
game at all
have it going to look at the solitaire
game which is just a single player
trying to minimize the number of moves
and for this you can consider for
example the optimal number of moves
required by a strategy assuming that the
the cards are just thrown out at random
right they have a uniform random
ordering of the cards and then you start
pointing to cards and picking and
looking at them let tfn be the optimal
number of moves required in expectation
then there's a paper from 13 that gives
some non-trivial upper and lower bounds
and T of n I won't stay put they are
because we have basically the the type
you know really tight results so T of n
is now known up to less than a constant
kind of term right so this is roughly
one point six one times n okay and the
paper itself has a fairly non-trivial
amount of enumerative combinatorics
going on and it's fun to look at
sometimes anyway so this work is not
even related to this and because all of
these results are assuming that the
player who's playing this game has
perfect memory so whenever they see a
card then from then on they just know
what's there right and that's kind of
defeats the point of this game if you
think about it the whole point of memory
is that you know humans can't really
remember all the things that they're
saying right so the right way to model
this game I think to get any kind of
complexity theory take insight is to say
what can a memory bounded player do a
smaller player so this is going to be
our set up so we have n pairs of picture
cards and I'll think of each picture as
a number and 1 2 up to some polynomial
in n so it's not like it yeah
it's not like an unusually large number
so it's an order log and bit suffice to
write down the picture of the card
by the way if this were not the case
then a hashing trick ensures that you
may as well think of this is the case so
so yeah it's a really without loss of
generality type assumption so so let's
say a player is playing this game and
they happen to flip a total of T cards
in the worst case and they use at most s
bits of space throughout their algorithm
so that's estimates of how much they can
remember about whatever they have seen
so far so what can you each picture feel
exactly twice yes so that's a promise
yeah well no not in terms of our results
or yeah main result is going to be a
lower bound which will work even in that
case but for the upper bound it's more
interesting if you can do it for a
larger range here yeah so there is a
deterministic strategy that achieves
this trade-off space times time is N
squared and this deterministic strategy
even works as a plain old streaming
algorithm you could think of the cards
as being arriving in a stream one up to
the other this is the same as saying you
must examine the cards from the card
number one all the way up to card number
two N and then make another pass if
needed and so on so forth
and what happened there
so it's not hard to see that using s
space you can solve this whole thing in
n / s passes and each pass is basically
an amount of time because they're
looking at every card once so that gives
you this trade-off s times T equals N
squared and the algorithm also only ever
compares two cards for equality so it's
never doing any arithmetic with these
numbers that are on the cards although
it could in principle right there's no
no reason to disallow that okay anyhow
so one relatively easy theorem we can
prove is that if you have a
deterministic algorithm and this is all
it can do that it can only compare cards
for equality then this trade-off is
right you must have s times T equals
Omega N squared I'm hiding some log
factors yeah precise about the model so
let's say okay so the model is that you
can store a working set which you insist
of just some you know the cards are
opaque objects and working sets
cardinality is bounded by this s let's
say yeah so this is proved by an
adversarial strategy that I will not
describe I won't go into this any more
it does require a little bit of care
it's not totally trivial but it's not
too hard but I mainly want to talk about
is is this result so so this was only
equality and here I'm going to allow
arbitrary operations with the integers
on the cards and I'm going to allow
randomized algorithms and in this
setting we can prove this trade-off that
s times T squared is n cubed which is
not as good as s times P equals n
squared so at the end of comment about
optimality of this or not reward but
anyway this is what we can prove and to
model a general algorithm we're going to
use branching programs as you might
suspect so let me talk about a bunch of
related things but not talked about but
mention a bunch of related things in the
branching program world that are all
quite old as you will see and I said
this is a classic topic so the
granddaddy of all these papers is paper
of board in
cook that introduced sort of a
ubiquitous technique for proving these
branching program levels so they
consider the sorting problem so you have
n integers in some reasonable range n
you have to sort them and they give a
trade-off of roughly of the form s times
T equals N squared and they introduced a
certain counting technique that we will
soon get to see and by applying this
same counting technique and then adding
more and more ingredients on top a whole
bunch of other results quatro got proven
I should single out one of these results
due to Paul which considers this problem
we have you have n integers between 1
and N and you've talked put all the
unique ones so all the integers that
appear exactly once in the list ok so he
shows that this requires s times P
equals N squared and this is somewhat
reminiscent of the kind of thing that we
have to solve if instead of outputting
things that appear exactly once I
require to output all the elements that
appear exactly twice say it doesn't
fundamentally change this problem and
this lobenstein works and that sounds an
awful lot like memory but actually
memory is easier than this because in
the memory game they have this extra
promise that the input is in fact just n
different pairs and somehow there's
something in Paul's argument that
requires a more general input to be
considered all right so they challenge
is to get some kind of lower bound even
under this promise and one can say the
same thing about the relation of memory
and sorting if you could sort your input
you can certainly solve the memory
problem so but that makes memory easier
than sorting so the lower bounds the
existing lower bounds don't apply okay
so just to be sure we're on the same
page let's describe this branching
program model the branching program is
like a decision tree except that they
are not making just decisions there we
are putting bigger things and also it
doesn't have to be a tree they can be it
would be a dag in general so let's say
we have this kind of layered dag every
node reads the variable
I remember the variables take values
from 1 up to R so there are children of
each node into the next layer
there'll be another variable and so on
so forth and as you read as you travel
as you traverse an edge you can decide
to output zero or more matches where a
match is a triple of this for my JV
which is a declaration that xie calls XJ
equals B I found value V at you know
guard location I on location J so if you
use time T that translates to this dag
having depth T and if you use space s
that translates to each layer of the
diag having at most two to the s notes s
bits corresponds to two to the s
different possible States at each layer
okay the model any questions about the
model itself
yes matches and it's okay if you have to
say match more than once let's say it is
yeah just deterministic okay I'll talk
about random at the very end right so
thanks for that question so I'm actually
going to describe the lower bound for
deterministic algorithms and then I'll
say at the end what you need to do to
get a randomized low bar okay so so this
is a theorem to spelled out more
carefully so this is called an Hardware
branching programs every our via
branching program provided R as a norm
or I think this was modal's question is
n enough and yes it is if it has length
3 and width at most 2 to the yes then
you have that trade-off okay so let's
say a little about how to prove this
hopefully be able to give you enough of
an outline of the proof that you'll be
able to fill in the details if you care
all right
divide time into stages so this is the
thing that Borden and cook did okay and
I don't tell you what's the advantage of
dividing time into stages so a stage
consists of roughly are consecutive
layers of the branching program let's
make once at stage each stage has a
bunch of nodes that could be thought of
as routes of sub branching programs that
consists of only that stage so we'll
zoom zoom in on one of these sub
branching programs and try to say
something interesting about it okay so
for this we make one important
definition yes yes this good point here
yeah soon there will be an equation with
both capital R and little R thank you
all right so so we'll call a stage
productive for an input X if when you
run this frenching program on this input
then at this stage it produces at least
two T number of outputs where T is a
parameter that will set at some point
okay so recall that a total of n outputs
have to be given okay so this means by
an easy easy pigeonhole kind of argument
that if you have just supposed towards a
contradiction that you have too few
stages for n over two T then for every
input there must be some stage in the
tree that is productive and then by
again averaging there exists one single
stage that's productive for at least two
T over n fraction of inputs okay so now
let's zoom in on this stage this one
stage which is productive for a large
fraction of inputs in your space
so I said this stage okay so let's say
it's this particular stage that we're
focusing on it's productive for many
inputs so they're at most two to the S
nodes over here right yeah if you if you
look at the top layer of the stage so by
another averaging argument at least one
of these nodes is productive in the
sense that there's sub branching program
rooted at it is productive for at least
two T over N times two to the - fraction
of inputs all right good
so from now on we just gotta focus on
this one sub branching program right
okay so let's set the parameter R to be
roughly this geometric mean of N and T
our main lemma is going to state that a
branching program of that height R is
productive for a randomly chosen X with
probability that's somehow this
exponentially small quantity okay it
depends on the setting of R over there
okay now on the other hand this this
branching program that was chosen by
this process has to be at least this
productive so it's at least this
productive and it moves that productive
so you get an equation you get an
inequality and T is still free so we get
to plug in T let's choose T equals s and
we get a contradiction because of the
fundamental fact that e is larger than
two
all right so because of a contradiction
we conclude miss B suppose that the
branching the overall branching program
had it post n over 2t stages so you must
have more than one over 2t stages plug
it all in and you get the trade off that
you're seeking yeah so that's the
outline now I'll zoom into this main
lemma yes what I'm using about B prime
is the height of small that's it for a
fixed X productively I mean we talked
about a branching program being
productive phoronix yeah productive
means at least I I'll repeat this
definition several times so at least two
T outputs are being produced right okay
so let's take this sub branching program
B prime that we've zoomed in on and just
unfold it to give give an actual tree so
it could it could have shared children
but just unfold them so that it's an
actual tree so now get a tree of this
height R remember R is said to be
roughly square root NT now let's choose
an X uniformly at random from our space
of all legal inputs and let PI of X
denote the path that this uniform input
X follows with industry so we'll define
the input X to be good if the following
thing happens so along this path we
produce at least Duty correct outputs
either it was productive for this input
and at least T at least half of these
outputs that are produced are of two
variables that were queried along this
path now notice that this path
corresponds to a sub branching programs
it's not the whole branching program so
even if you produce outputs at this
stage they may have been queried in some
previous stage they need not did not
need to be queried in this stage so so
we call it good if at least half of what
you're producing both queried along this
very path ok so we're gonna have two
levels the good case lemma which is that
the probability of X being good is
exponentially small and that is sort of
the more interesting one to prove and
then there's the bad case lemma which
says if X is bad then the probability of
it being productive is kind of also
exponentially small
and once you have these two things then
you can combine them using the well-born
trick of splitting an integral into two
parts and bounding the integrant in one
part and the domain and the other park
and you get this okay all right so so
that proves the main lemma so it now
remains to talk about lemma G and lemma
B so let's just spends with lemma B
first week I think it's less interesting
it's merely the following observation so
if X is bad and yet it's productive then
it means that quite a few of the outputs
you're giving so at least they're more
than T of the outputs you're giving our
based on guesswork
so you didn't query the variables along
this path and yet you're declaring that
the value of some input is equal to
certain very certain value okay how
likely is this to be correct well a
total of our queries are made by this
sub branching program so the domain size
is capital R so that leaves our - our
values that you never saw and any
unquiet variable could be equal to any
of these R - R values okay so the
probability that all of your
declarations are correct is you know
something like this which is
exponentially small in T in the branch
and so you have information yes yes so
right so the the point is that you're
now looking at and you're looking at a
uniformly random X which may or may not
even reach that node that's on top okay
so in fact most often you're uniformly
random X won't even reach the note that
you're analyzing okay so this
probability is a statement about what is
the probability that this uniformly
random X if you happen to start started
at this node by force then it will
produce these many correct outputs so I
operate a word here is correct so it's
producing these outputs of course
because the bread chip program sells
right this right this right this but
these are course not be correct
so when I use what do you use this memo
no I haven't used it yet but it's not
it's not gonna be used within here the
fact that the memory was small was used
a while back so when we
yes here when I did this to to the minus
s over here this n equal to use of the
fact that I made this this inequality
does not use it we don't care we aren't
falling it into a tree yes look at the
good case okay so here at least we drew
something somewhat interesting so once
again hex is good if at least two T
correct outputs are produced and at
least two of those outputs were of two
variables that'll actually quit in
dispel okay let's define a couple of
random variables so one is X which is
the number of matches that we found
among the queries that were made in this
path okay so this is this is the actual
number of matches that are supposed to
be you know at least T over here right
and let Y be a different random variable
where I say okay ignore what's happening
along this path by X and just say what
is the number of matches that I would
found if I just queried X 1 X 2 up to X
are just the first our variables now
depending on your disposition it's
either intuitively obvious that these
two variables are the same thing or it's
or it's the kind of thing that makes you
worried that something is wrong and I've
better be careful I am of the I'm of
type 2 and so I sat down and wrote down
the these two random variables
distributions you know in terms of
cardinalities of sets and wrote down the
bijection to make sure that there is
indeed the symmetry that I'm claiming
yes there is these variables are
actually identical in distribution okay
so to to bound the tale of X it suffices
to bound the tale of boy okay now but Y
has an easier formulation it doesn't
depend on this this path whatever this
thing is happy it's a much much easier
thing so you can in fact abstract it
like this you have a bag which has to
end balls and there are two of each
color so they're in different colors and
I'm going to pick our balls from this
bag without replacement and count how
many match it matching pairs I got okay
let that number be Y that's the same
random variable okay so this Y is
clearly a sum of indicators where IJ
says I did an indicator for getting both
the balls of
color J you can compute the expectation
so straightforward exercise and you get
something like R squared over four N and
remember that we want to bound the tail
so we want to know what's the
probability that you get at least T
given that the expectation is so much so
roughly speaking Chernoff bound should
tell you that it's exponential in minus
T times log of this number over that
number there's an extra e because the
Chernoff bond doesn't quite say that but
you can get it there's one catch though
you can't quite - Chernov because these
IJ's are not independent however they're
dependent in the right way so they're
they're negatively associated to the
formal way to argue this is to actually
do a formal proof that these things are
negatively associated it's it's a couple
of lines if you know this technology
okay so I'm not going to go more into
that with that proved so to recap this
proves the main lemma which lower and
upper bounds this probability of being
productive and there's also the lower
bound from the earlier board and
counting argument combine them and you
get your contradiction now if we had a
randomized algorithm nested of this
deterministic thing that we've been
talking about what you do is change the
definition of productivity just say that
but you change the outer counting
argument to say that well you don't have
to produce all n matches but let's say
you have to produce 90% of the matress
90% of the time so all of these factors
of 90% only play in this we just adjust
you just put put the right factor in
front of this quantity
nothing changes over here and you still
get your contradiction yeah yeah so the
model of randomness that that encodes is
a distribution of a deterministic
branching programs which is from the
lower bounds point of view a strong kind
of model from the upper bounds point of
view it could be an unnatural model the
distribution of a branching program so
the answer your question we access the
randomness here since they're not giving
an algorithm I'm not to bother
about that but you know in a minute bill
actually right now we're gonna talk
about that to a little okay so so some
open problems
so the first lower bound that I just
didn't prove but claimed who was that
space times time is Omega N squared if
all you can all you can do is the
Equality queries
I think this bound should work for
randomized algorithms and for a while we
even thought we had a proof but the
subtle bug and I haven't figured out how
to fix it so I leave this as an open
problem yeah if you if you have thoughts
about it by all means come see me I'm
here for the rest of the week and for a
while after that too happy to exchange
notes about what it is that we tried
different open question is is that low
is the lower bound we proved s T squared
equals n cube actually tight it never
even occurred to us that this might be
tied we thought that this is okay it's
just some artifact of the way we are
proving the lower bound and the true
result is s T equals N squared and that
may still be the case but then meaning
had a chat with Paul at some point when
she was visiting and Paul pointed us to
this amazing result of their so which
gives this straight of upper bound for a
very close problem of element
distinguish the decision problem so
things are a little bit different there
what's interesting about this upper
bound is it really uses this heavy kind
of randomization where what they get is
a distribution over deterministic
branching programs that achieves that
particular trade-off so in a sense yeah
it needs to use more random bits then
the branching program actually has
memory available to it but in terms of
actually storing or storing information
about the input it's it's s bounded and
the algorithm is highly non-trivial it
uses Floyd's cycle finding algorithm as
its core and has a lot of neat tricks on
top of that to identify one colliding
pair in the input in small space and say
square root n time so we did try to see
if these ideas can help us solve our
problem because our problem is also
about finding equal pairs but somehow a
lot of effort is spent finding just one
equal pair and we have to find all the
equal pairs so their ideas don't
directly give us an algorithm for our
problem it's possible that there's some
further trickery which will do the job
ok good so there's a chance that that
lower bound actually might be tight or
not maybe we can get a stronger lower
bound maybe we can get a stronger lower
bound for somewhat more restricted
branching program models such as
comparison printing programs where you
allow more than equality test so I allow
actual ordered comparisons but it's
still not full generality and not
allowing arbitrary computations on the
input
so there are there is a result of Yahoo
in this model giving that type of
trade-off for element distinct methods
possible that's some technique some
other techniques could work for our
problem but anyhow these are open
questions yeah
please let me know if you have thoughts
on any of them thank you yeah yeah it's
you do almost the first thing that might
come to mind open up the first several
cards as much as your memory will allow
memorize everything that's in this set
and now so you can do it on the
streaming algorithm so just treat all
the cards of the one stream that let's
talk about separately there's a
different thing yeah yeah the two-player
game is an entirely different business
here so there is there is something to
do with the parity of how many cards how
many pairs remain to be discovered and
so on it's surprising it's not at all
obvious that there should be a strategy
okay it's the thing in the beginning